Sự nếm mút bắt hình mẹt quân bốc trái sức dội châu 2 tằng sấu, nhiều nhà rất bị trái lần, người dân hỏng rộng hỏng trái.
Cô lắm, hỏi đó là khoảng 18 giờ, lửa buông lên tại sử nếm mút trên đường hương lộ 2, phương bình chỉ đồng.
Cô nhanh cùng người dân xúc quanh điểm cách chữa trái nhưng bất thành.
Giòn chứ nhiều các liệu dễ trái, bọn lửa nhưng trong các thường hỏng bộ nhà sường,
hàng trụ bố dân xấu xác vách trải ra ngoài lãi nạ.
Bọn lửa, cây khói đảm tình dựa, hỏi lần tố nhật lần.
Cảm lần, hỏi lần, hỏi lần tố nhật lần.
Cảm lần thì thì thì thì tầy lần là người dân,
lần thì cái cổ người nàng cho em, cho em phải không truyền phương.
Chúng ta ở đây là mất trái lần.
Cái lần, con chứng chứng chứng đó thì xơ tải nó mà rửa trái lần.
Cái xác phòng trái trụ trái điều xa của hần chú trị sĩ đến nịch trường.
sau phòng của giờ đã trải được thống trẻ. Vụ trải khiến một công nhân bị thương ở trên,
không nhà sường đổ sập phản toàn. Nhưng nhà rất liên kể bị trải lan,
khu vực mất hiện khu phục bộ,
mình nhân và thiệt hại đang được gương quan trức nạn là gió.